the spread of the corona virus in the
European Union challenges our health
systems we need to protect our health
workers who are in the first line of
defense against the virus
we must safeguard them with protective
equipment masks gloves protective
garments etc we work on three fronts
first we are working with the industry
to ramp up production second we need to
keep in the EU the protective equipment
that we need this is why we adopted
today an export authorization scheme for
protective equipment this means that
such medical Goods can only be exported
to non EU countries with the explicit
authorization of the EU governments this
is the right thing to do
because we need that equipment for our
health care systems third we need to
share that equipment in the European
Union national bands on selling
protective equipment to other member
states are not good we need to help each
other no country can produce on its own
what it needs
today it is Italy that rapidly needs
large quantities of medical Goods but in
a few weeks other countries will need it
too by producing more keeping it in the
European Union and sharing with each
other we can protect our health workers
patients and contain the spread of the
virus this is why I propose this
European solution today also we need to
keep goods flowing across Europe without
obstacles just imagine as we increase
production of medical equipment
factories cannot get the components they
need in time thousands of bus and truck
drivers are stranded at internal borders
on parking lots creating more health
risk and disrupting our supply chains if
we do not take action now shops will
start facing difficulties in refilling
their stocks of certain products coming
from elsewhere in the single market in
this moment of crisis it is of at
most importance to keep our internal
market going in general measures taken
at national level can only be effective
if they are coordinated with neighboring
countries in particular in border
regions the European Commission is
working around the clock with the
national governments on all these fronts
tomorrow we will launch joint public
procurement with member states for
testing kits and respiratory ventilators
these are badly needed for our patients
across Europe also tomorrow we will
present guidelines to national
governments on border measures
protecting people's health should not
block goods and essential staff from
reaching patient's health systems
factories and shops we will be
successful if we work together and
rapidly on a coordinated response the
challenge we face requires it